Elon Musk is now the CEO of Twitter he
felt that going to Mars wasn't enough
and he walked in to Twitter offices with
the sink
s
let that sink in people you get it uh
Benny Johnson on Twitter friend of the
show he was one of the first people to
break that Elon Musk had fired
Vegeta the head of legal policy trust
and safety who made the decision to
permanently suspend Donald Trump and you
guys remember her she of course was the
one who went on Joe Rogan's podcast with
Tim Poole and pretty much dropped the
ball we should have seen all of this
coming so let's start with that Viva I
uh take it well first off you're a new
Floridian everyone knows that you fled
Canada you're here in free Florida but
you pay attention to a lot of the tech
stuff I mean this this Elon thing this
is all good for people that like free
speech and freedom right well okay it's
it's a risk first of all that the joke
let that sink in makes no sense if you
don't understand he's bringing a sink in
I thought it was a computer and it took
me forever to get the joke it's an
actual sink
it looks good he's certainly been
walking the walk to some extent I still
have my own concerns because Elon is
involved in businesses that rely on
government authorization government uh
approvals to some extent he's not
corruption free he's not blackmail free
it's conceivable he might succumb to the
pressure of don't do certain things
um on Twitter or we might frustrate some
of your other businesses which are
heavily reliant on government
authorization but so far so good and
anything that makes AOC unhappy uh might
be a good thing to a great many people
all right perfect segue so let's get to
the AOC stuff and then malice I want you
to comment on that so AOC she's not
happy that a billionaire is going to own
Twitter she seems to have no problem
with the billionaire who owns the
Washington Post but that's a separate
aside uh here's a tweet from AOC LMAO at
a billionaire earnestly trying to sell
people on the idea that free speech is
actually an eight-month subscription
plan to which Elon musk reply to your
feedback is appreciated now pay eight
dollars and then in perfect troll form
he posted this from aoc's website yeah
she sells a sweatshirt on her website
for uh 58 just on the factual side of
this thing uh Elon is not going to
charge everyone eight dollars he is
potentially going to charge people eight
dollars to be verified so that you would
know that you're talking to the real
person uh malice you must love the troll
portion of this right that Elon is not
just that he bought the thing and that
maybe Free Speech will be defended a bit
more uh but the troll part is kind of
this is malice territory can we put her
sweatshirt up again did you guys notice
she's got those upside down exclamation
points yeah around Ocasio
because you know if you're writing in
Spanish you're going to have an upside
down exclamation point in the middle of
someone's name that's just logic um I
absolutely love it and I absolutely love
that uh not only is Elon taking the
fight to these horrible people another
good example Dave was earlier in the
week when Stephen King America's
favorite aging lesbian uh was stamping
her feet about how I'm not gonna pay
twenty dollars a month to be verified
the guy's worth nine figures and Elon
Musk is like hey how about eight dollars
and he had no reply because for years
Twitter has been a safe space for
members of the enemy class they can spew
their nonsense and know that they would
have no repercussions the best example
of this of course was in covid uh when
they can spread complete lies such as
the fact that we need social distancing
such as the fact that if you have the
vaccine you're not going to spread it to
other people and no if anyone who
challenged them on this lost their
entire accounts let alone the ability to
just tweet one or two things about it